[Music]
and evidence
saves lives news I hope so something
about Louis Watson wasn't met normally
we've had no thank you a Missouri
governor halted a man's executions hours
before in light of new DNA evidence
there's so awsome seen this one oh thank
goodness for the Dena yes I sometimes I
really like the death penalty but like
in some cases like this all right even
might just kill the wrong person yeah
but like maybe maybe we can have the
death penalty for someone who we have
definitive like this video of him doing
it there's a video of someone doing it
now while he's doing it his screaming
out his social security number let's
kill that [ __ ] yeah there's got
to be like triple confirmation I think
that those are the ones that are over
mm-hmm like if you have his hair
follicle is just getting flakes and then
meanwhile he's [ __ ] tagging up his
birthday inside that let's kill that guy
yeah so this uh stories about Marcellus
Williams
he's now 48 years old but back in 1998
there was a woman that was killed her
name was Felicia Gale she was killed at
the age of 42 I don't wanna say I said
alright P okay that's that's good that's
good that's like saying that's
respectable
yeah so Marcellus was 29 at the time huh
in 2001 Marcellus is found guilty in the
stabbing of Felicia and the evidence
that they had was police found the
laptop from the victim's husband was
sold by Marcellus but then it was laptop
back in 1998 was probably like [ __ ]
this Dickens yeah what did they do they
must have been reached another thing
that works against him was that some of
her personal items were found in his
trunk of his car and then another thing
was the fact that there was a testimony
from his former girlfriend and his
former cellmates saying that he had
admitted to the murder
what are you do quickiy he bleeding I'm
sorry wait how come people ratted him
out but he didn't do it so he is
insisting that they both were trying to
go after the ten thousand dollar
information reward [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
was DNA recovered at the scene but none
of the DNA evidence matches his DNA and
that's why the governor puts it took
that long maybe put a hold on clearly
hours before his execution
nightly I'm gonna [ __ ] yeah back in
2001 was when he found where he was
found guilty of the murder yeah that
sucks ass so keen yeah all he did was
sell a laptop so he was involved in the
burglary which then turned into a
robbery once they discovered that she
was in the home whoever killed her and
it but it was crazy cuz she was stabbed
43 times
that's personal yeah and they are saying
like the cops are saying that you know
if you're stabbing someone that much
like you're bound to have some of your
DNA you know go somewhere in the scene
but they didn't find they didn't find
Marcela's DNA they found some other
unknown man's DNA what what if like
dating like she got robbed right and
then some jealous baby daddy came over
and in stabbed at her yeah the same time
same night coincidental yeah yeah it's
cuz they're saying at the time of their
entire trial but they didn't have the
same DNA technology that they have
and now they reran it and then yeah it
turned out that it's not his it's some
other dudes and so then that's when
there was an this online petition on
change.org that had I got over two
hundred and sixty thousand signatures
against his execution so then that's
when the lawyers and everyone we're just
asking the Missouri governor if they can
issue a stay of execution meaning like
to halt it so they can further
investigate and really find out who is
responsible for this can you imagine
they telling you that you're gonna die
tomorrow and then for sixteen years
you're like I didn't [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] die tomorrow for
something I never did
oh it's suck yeah there was an interview
that he said that in prison he's been
telling people for years I didn't do it
and he never changed a story it was just
always the same story I'm never gonna
admit to it and hopefully one day
someone out there were like those are
like eight hours hours I saw a little
book about a little book a little one
for the last meal before they die yeah
with the requesting some of it is weird
what was one of the weirdest ones I mean
like I had like one olive a child I
remember talking about that I'm taking
years someone requested a child need a
child I remember a child yeah what no I
didn't see that I just yeah I saw stuff
like an olive or like just one olive
because they don't have olives in there
you're just wandering all over that's
all well like it's peas chicken from KFC
yeah like fast food or just mac and
cheese or like a pint of ice cream and
it was like comfort food it wasn't it
was nothing like I want the [ __ ]
steak and ribs and stuff one guy was
like I just want you guys to donate a
pizza to the homeless I never did it Wow
that's that yeah so luckily he's alive
now but they're just gonna really
investigate there hasn't been a
timetable set like to see how long this
is gonna be on hold for but well so he's
not he's not freed he's not off the hook
he's just not gonna die yeah cuz he
still stole some [ __ ] yeah
yeah dude like 16 years I think that's
done in fear of dying every [ __ ] day
like especially the night before I can't
even imagine what that feels like
no maybe the world has to change and we
have to get better technology and then
like maybe if you do the crime then you
should do something to balance out what
you did so like let's say I stole a tire
that maybe what you need to do is go
back and patch tires for free for 600
years or something 600 years is crazy it
is like oh I killed and took a life then
you go give a life you donate a kidney
you come in a cup or something I don't
oh no that's giving life I thought
you're gonna give birth donating sperm
or you become a surrogate daddy mother
daddy mother you become an incubator for
babies I really I really like the idea
of just having the death penalty for
people who are just like dude it's so
you you can't even [ __ ] deny it you
know yeah why you deny Charles Manson
yeah yeah we just forgot mom and those
things were death penalty I'm down and
for the super violent one I won't like
been on the non painlessly why do we do
that again why do we not have a death
penalty it's cruel and inhumane cuz some
states have it it's because of just like
this that's they make a mistake yeah I'd
rather have they'd rather kill no people
at all than actually kill an innocent
man
yeah that's what it is that's fair what
is your last meal so um okay so that
restaurant in Orange County bird art
they have a sauce it's my family's
restaurant so they have a saw is that a
shameless plug bro it's not the mole the
dip sauce yeah so that's my news it's
like it yeah so that's two components
right there's like the meat side of it
and then you pour it into like the the
thickening sauce when you take that meat
side only and you put it in pasta best
shooters [ __ ] good like so good and
my great about to blow your two friends
my grandmother my grandmother used to
like she used to like save me the meat
sauce before she put it in the beginning
like we don't talk anymore it's [ __ ]
like [ __ ] you still like [ __ ] you but I
still want that recipe but you shall
have it
[ __ ] you grandma you [ __ ] ho Virginia
rep see I still have the recipe in my
brain you know I can still make it like
what he's still but I still never say
that to my gramma you could with my girl
okay I believe it [ __ ] about that with
my like I just want to eat that with my
pasta so bad cuz when she used to make I
was a kid I used to eat like seven bowls
of that [ __ ] like non-stop it was so
good yeah what do I want
I I want noodles and soup what kind of
noodles um I knew you wanted it's like
this type of rice noodle um it's not
like the really flat thin ones but it's
not like it's really hard to describe
but it's basically flat noodles is it
Chinese yeah it's tiny slice like child
chow fun no it was not child fine is it
me thing no me even even yeah but yeah
it's just type of noodles and then like
the broth of my mom usually mace which
is like really simple does it fish or
chicken or beef chicken sometimes pork
so you they're gonna the gels gonna have
your mama come over and make the last
meal I know you like it for you would it
be like two pounds of thirteen or one
yeah well I don't know what I want from
a main course but I know for the dessert
like the last flavor and maybe gonna ask
for dessert too like the let well it's a
warm meal it's worth sports um I think
the last layer of my mouth I want is
like fruit so it's like pineapple
watermelon mango strawberry with the he
and the Machine and lemon all
I'll ask for a cake with a nail file so
I could chisel my way out so you're
gonna ask them to make it for you I want
a cake with a [ __ ] nail file in it in
fact if you already have a bottom of
paying keister dude for sure
I'm escaping that [ __ ] anyway
she's so whole sentence her whole prison
sentence she's a lot of diamond her
little my dream is to be like El Chapo
and have my disciples break me out of
prison
oh I won't build a tunnel for you thank
you thank you a long time you're the
only one that's gonna do that it's fine
I know another word I'll meet you
halfway with it with the threat file
that they baked for me I wouldn't wake
up on time don't forget to do the other
half hope you guys enjoyed that video if
you did a really cool way to communicate
that to us and for you to never miss
another video is by subscribing
so click on that little subscribe button
and you'll never miss an episode for the
next episode click right up here